good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways that you
can start taking more action here's what
happened I'm on jury duties my Duty's
Duty my entire calendar is cleared right
they give us a very long lunch what do I
do
I don't sit and chill it out I don't sit
and say well I don't have anything
scheduled I email the team we bang out
episode 114 of the askgaryvee show I
email Matt my assistant he's hanging out
over there that's kind of creepy looks
looks super suspicious
anyway anyway Matt's here so what we're
gonna go through a bunch of stuff that
we have to execute against I have two
calls right after I do this video Phil
Toronto from vayner/rse the fun is
coming and having a meeting that was
going to be at 11:30 p.m. tonight he's
coming to meet me at 1:00 basically what
I'm fascinated by is that people like to
say they hustle and I talk about working
the whole day and then I've talked to
you guys a lot about well it's not about
how much you sleep it's what you do
while you're awake and this is a perfect
example of something that I've watched a
lot of my contemporaries and a lot of
you the vaynernation
write that say they love to hustle when
something happens a meeting gets
canceled right there's a curveball it's
a snow day right they take that as
vacation time instead of adjusting to it
see the truth of the matter is being
efficient executing shooting for those
big goals is predicated on your actions
do you take a extra-long lunch from jury
duty to say you know what cool I'm going
to chill and watch youtube videos or do
you hustle your face off and try to cram
as much in you know I I'm excited that
that's my first thought now look I get
it I'm sitting on a high chair right now
and talking down to like you should do
this I'm really not I'm really not I'm
really not telling you what you should
do I'm really not trying to be a guru
I'm not really trying to be too cool and
say hahaha look at me not you I'm really
really really not really just making
these videos not for the people that you
find this condescending not for the few
people that find it motivational
making this video for the people that
are foolish right the ones that tell me
to my face every day that yeah you know
and really want it and don't recognize
the actions that it takes to get there
so I'm making this video for a very
small percentage of you to the left look
Gary thinks he's so cool to the right
that's the best number complete
blindness no the middle the middle my
friends so many of you that actually
want this have the skills to do this
right and sometimes once in a while just
need to see a different version of it to
understand ah right
ah to me this is an AA video right did
you mail it in did you mail in that
fifteen minute fifteen minute call got
cancelled you had a packed day fifteen
hour day they got cancelled what are you
doing at fifteen minutes and by the way
sometimes those 15 minutes are
absolutely worth calling your mom
calling your daughter face on with your
kids but it's just making every minute
count every minute has to count every
minute has to count if you want so much
because you just don't have as many of
them as you think you just don't
many years ago at a talk I was speaking
to Rich DeVos when he was on his way up
Rich DeVos the president of Amway were
5.3 billion dollars today started off
knocking on doors selling soap and he
was working his way up and I asked him I
said what have you found
what's the most important quality of
successful people and he said Brian he
said we found there's a direct
relationship I still remember him
telling me this between how quickly a
person takes action on a new idea and
how like it is they'll ever take action
on any idea at all and so the action
orientation is the critical thing we
watch people everybody hears the same
things they hear the same ideas but then
we watch and we see how quickly they
take action and if a person takes action
quickly on a new idea the chances are
they're going to be successful go up by
hundreds of percent now what most people
do is they say that's a great idea so
wonderful idea I love I'm going to do
that whoo-hoo I'm so excited but before
I apply it I need to take a vacation to
a wonderful place called Sunday I'll and
so they go to some day I'll and they
live on some day I'll and who are they
surrounded with on Sunday I'll other
people on Sunday I'll and what is the
chief topic of conversation on some day
I oh yes it's their excuses what's your
excuse for not taking action what's your
excuse for not getting one what's your
excuse for not losing weight getting out
of debt building your business write in
your book getting your book finished
getting your damn book started you know
in other words what what is what's your
experience and I'll share excuses you
know that's a good excuse I haven't used
that one for a long time battle battle
gate that'll take me another year and so
what they do is they sit around and the
bottom 80% of the population lives on
Sunday I own most of their lives they
all have these great resolutions but and
these wonderful intentions but what's
their hold to help a bit it's good
intentions and I'm going to do that
someday somebody so it's rule number one
for success is whatever you learn here
vote yourself off the island no more
some day I'll either do it or don't do
it I need you to transition from the I
today ah whoo that's right I said it
transition from the I and what's an eye
the eye is an idea that's all it is it's
an idea so I want us to do more a than I
that's right I want us to live in the a
and not that
what do I mean by that some people man
they got an idea and all you do is talk
talk talk every time you get an idea you
pick up the phone you call your homegirl
you three-way you get on conference call
and you're getting excited about your
idea all right
you telling your mom about it your daddy
about it and you there's more life in
you when you talk about the idea then
you put any action in it are you hearing
me so do me a huge favor write the idea
down and shut up you heard what I said
write the idea down and shut up you
ain't going to share your idea with 50
people write the idea down and boom get
to steppin baby get to the action
because listen to me very closely your
success is not determined on just what
you say now I'm not just I'm not
disagreeing with you got to speak stuff
into existence I'm not disagreeing with
that but I'm telling you you can't talk
about it all the time you got to be
about it so I want some action
so that what does that mean that means
when you wake up in the morning there's
24 hours in a day after you finish
sleeping right and I don't know how much
sleep you need right there's this big
debate
ETI much sleep do I need I don't have a
slice I di know how much I need you
might need fine you might need six you
might need seven you might need eight I
don't know that's your business but
listen to what I'm telling you after you
have finished sleeping after you finish
eating and if you just that immature and
you need to get your play on everyday
you need to play video games I don't
know you need to play cards I don't know
what you need to do whatever you need to
do after you finish exercising I'm
telling you to spend the rest of that
time in action and you're gonna separate
yourself from everybody why because most
people all they doing is talk talk talk
talk that's all they doing is pop talk
talk talk and then getting pumped up and
then getting excited from talking so I'm
saying get out of neutral and get it in
the drive the majority of your day so on
Monday I want you to have ten write down
the things that do list and I want you
to say at the end of the day if I wrote
down 20 things what did I get done and
I'm trying to tell you at the end of
Monday at the end of Tuesday at the
winds Wednesday at the end of Thursday
at the you get what I'm saying
this ain't rocket science at the end of
your week if you were supposed to get 60
things done and you got 40 things done
you're gonna be average at the end of
the week I just want to get 60 things
and you got 50 done you're gonna be
pretty good but at the end of the week
if you got 58 59
6
things done out of 60 let me tell you
something you're gonna separate yourself
from everybody else are you hear what
I'm saying
all right all I'm trying to tell you is
this don't let your words guide you let
your actions guide you are you hearing
me
don't let your words guide you let your
actions guide you and if you spend a
majority of your day writing stuff down
and then fulfilling it you're gonna be
tight work so stop listen to me stop
getting all pumped up about an idea
everybody has one everybody got a dream
everybody got to go stop dreaming about
it stop talking about it and get up and
do something about it that a baby that
action that action that grinding that
waking up and grinding over here my
final one one of the functions of belief
is taking action we did a survey of
about 2,000 top entrepreneurs and we
noticed that one of the things that
people who win in that world have is a
bias for action if they have an
inspiration they act on it I mean how
many of you have ever had a great idea
talked about it thought about it didn't
do it then someone else did it was
successful when you went on I should
have done that maybe it was by that
piece of property it was all that we all
have that piece of property we wish we'd
bought you know anyway so we're going to
be looking at the idea that taking
action is part of Law of Attraction see
a lot of people think you just sit in
your room meditate visualize having the
perfect car the perfect house the
perfect relationship and then it'll kind
of just come to you and I always say
unless you live at the bottom of the
hill where there's a road it's probably
not going to be a Cadillac show up in
your living room right so think about
this the last six letters of the word
attractions fell what AC tion action now
there's two kinds of actions that are
critical there's obvious actions if you
want a certain kind of car you should go
down and test-drive it you should find
out how much it costs you should see
what it costs to maintain it you should
go you know spend I like the test-drive
a car three or four times go down to the
dealer take a camera stick my head out
the window say take a picture of me I'll
be back buy it
put it up on my refrigerator look at it
every day eventually you know those kind
of things produce car right saving for
it and so forth but there are also
things called inspired actions all of a
sudden you get an inspiration to do
something and you didn't know what it
was you don't have a sense of like how's
this rationally going to make sense for
me to move forward in my life I'll give
you an example a friend of mine dr.
Ignatius Piazza graduates chiropractic
school he wants to move to Monterey
near Pebble Beach where the golf course
is and he gets there and he says to the
local Chiropractic Association like to
join you and like you to help me get my
practice started and they said we don't
need any more chiropractors we have one
chiropractor for every eight people in
this area as too many now he could have
said okay let the external reality
control his internal experience but he
doesn't do that he said I'm going to
think about this and visualize it and
believe in it and something will come
that I will do and what came to him to
do was to take six months before he
opened his office and put a pin where he
wanted his office and then concentric
circles knock on every door in every
neighborhood saying hi I'm a new doctor
in town could I ask you a few questions
you know I'm starting this practice
should I open from 5:00 to 9:00 in the
morning and or should I be open from
5:00 until 9:00 at night for people who
have 9 to 5 jobs which would be better
should I advertise in this paper or that
paper should I call it Ignatius Piazza
chiropractic or chiropractic West then
his last question was the fire of an
open house would you like to receive an
invitation they said yes he wrote it
down now over six months he knocked on
12,500 doors talked to 6500 people and
gathered over 4,000 names of people who
said yes I'd like an invitation to your
open house now when he opened his office
six months later in a town that did not
need another chiropractor according to
the professionals his first month in
practice he netted seventy two thousand
dollars in his first year in practice
his gross income was over $1,000,000 I
was giving a talk and mentioning this
story just about five years ago and this
happened about 25 years ago someone said
he knocked on my door
and he left his card and two years later
I needed the chiropractor and I called
him because we work with people we know
we've had an experience with right so he
trusted his intuition he took action on
it other people would say oh if I can't
have what I want you got to be willing
to take the action but you cannot just
get into analysis paralysis either and
that's why you also have to on a daily
basis actualize your dreams what I mean
by that well I'm sure you I hope you
read some Abraham Maslow and this
concept of self-actualization becoming
our best but you have to actually show
up every day and into yourself forward
toward these dreams and not only show up
every day and once in a while into
yourself I mean every day you have to
actually take an action that moves you
forward not just research not just
thinking look the power of an intention
is great but without any initiative it's
dead right a dream is great but without
any movement it's dead you have to be
moving towards every day you can send an
email every day you can make a call
every day you can write something every
day you can create something every day
you can contribute something every day
but it has to be daily otherwise it will
never become actualized the highest
performers in the world didn't get there
because they were lucky they worked at
it longer than everyone else they had a
better work ethic and something that
necessary always worked harder they work
smarter because they were doing the
research they were taking the time to
visualize how they would be distinct
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it keep
every single day momentum going and if
you don't do that there's no chance
think about what's the Holy Grail
between somebody taking action or not
it's one word certainty when somebody is
absolutely certain they you know the
common word it believed right but you
know you can believe at a general level
or you can believe what's certain when
you're absolutely certain that if I do
this it's going to get that result and
that result is going to change my life
you'll do it when you think it
absolutely is not going to work you're
never going to do it the middle no-man's
land of maybe it'll work maybe it won't
that's the piece that kills people
right so if it's a must for you you got
to make it work right in our case right
it's an example it's not a must for you
and you're not sure you don't know what
to do so I years ago I'd look around and
say okay how do people get themself to
follow through they haven't been
following through what's the difference
and I started interviewing hundreds of
people literally eventually thousands
cuz I had thousands of my events so I'd
ask the group to give me their feedback
they came up with his model it's like
the holy grail of belief or the holy
grail of Momentum's like the difference
between what makes the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer right and the
difference we all know is mindset
they're like how is that bill so this is
my idea create a stupid little four
little boxes and I'll scribble it here
for it you think about the first thing
that determines whether you can do
something or not and I put that in this
first box at the top here on the left
side that's potential like what's the
potential of EMV like when you guys
started you proved something no one had
done in history around the four-minute
mile right for godly knows how many
centuries they're trying to run a
four-minute mile roger bannister does it
how did he do it do you remember you did
it in this industry right you made a
million bucks in a day no one had ever
done that in history right now if you
did it a bunch of the guys are doing it
the case if we came possible roger
bannister didn't just go physically
practice he made a shift in his hat he
practiced in his head because he could
never achieve it physically so he had a
change of his head first so the result
became certain enough he believed it and
his body got him through after roger
bannister in that four-minute mile
within two years 37 people around a
four-minute mile when no one in history
never done now here's how it works
the potential for anybody getting your
product is extraordinary they can do
what you've done is much more or less
they can do whatever they want to do the
potentials there the markets proven that
whether or not they happen the potential
is a lot to deal with what action they
take which is the question of key to me
with right like you know copy owns
potential to not take an action and we
all know that the action that take is
going to determine the results they get
that's pre obvious so most people have a
belief about what their real potential
isn't matter what you tell them and then
affects how much action they take and of
course that affects the result and then
ironically that result reinforces their
belief and their belief that's it so
I'll give an example let's say a person
has unlimited potential we all agree but
they take little action little results
why because they have to start with a
problem with their belief they don't
believe it's really going to happen for
me maybe for Frank Kearns because it's
got the cool hair and stuff or maybe
it's for you because you're so driven
but it's not me maybe Tony Robbins
because she's a freak up these big teeth
whatever their thought process is right
they got this thing right but what
happens is if you believe that there's
very little potential how much action
you're gonna take moppet little and when
you take a little potential with a
little action what kind of results you
get lousy little results we need a
little results what does that do to your
belief you go see I told you this was a
waste of time soldier this wouldn't work
and then what happens you tap even less
potential to take even less action even
the worst results and your belief gets
even weaker and this sucker feeds on
itself until you are in a downward
spiral poisonous it's poisonous in its
self-fulfilling now what if something
could happen that could come along and
fill you with a sense of absolute
certainty not like I believe but mean
well you know and you guys this case
mine as well we knew because we had to
because we burned the boats there was no
other option we had to find a way we had
we were gonna live that way we all did
it in different ways and for different
reasons but in essence that was it if
you get yourself in a state of certainty
that this is going to work I'm gonna
find the way and if this doesn't work I
will make the way then you tap a lot
more potential when you're circling your
potential you take massive action when
you take massive action you really
believe in something you get great
results when you get great results your
brain goes see I told you I was a stud I
told you this thing would work out now
you even stronger tap more potential
take greater action better results
that's how you went from 300 bucks in a
week to twenty five hundred and five
days to a hundred thousand and a month
to a million bucks in a day same thing
with you and we get momentum so when the
rich get richer and the poor get poorer
now some people go out they go well I'm
gonna take a bunch of action all right
I'm gonna open this product we're gonna
try it
they'll say to you I even did it but
it's like a Salesman who goes in knocks
on the door he knocks on 100 doors and
says exactly right yeah and even if he
doesn't say it verbally his face says it
because he doesn't believe it's going to
work so his voice his body the execution
is so weak maybe if he talks 100 people
somebody's gonna buy out of pity I'm
gonna want his kids to starve right but
he's not going to get the result so the
core difference in people is how do you
produce certain day when the world isn't
giving it to you you go out and try and
you try in your case you're a hundred
thousand of that nothing's working how
do you keep yourself going the way you
did it the way I did it the way you're
doing it we mean I've done it
consciously is we didn't change our
potential that was there and it wasn't
even taking more action taking more
action with belief is not gonna works
not going to change anything we got
results in our head that made us feel
certain as if it had already happened to
or Falls for you true alright so give me
an example some people know I'm not just
making this crap up well I mean just
like when I had nothing I already knew I
was driving like Ferraris and Porsches
and stuff because I always wanted those
cars I already knew I was going to have
them it was inevitable right I never -
no that was just my inevitable outcome
but how did you do that did you have a
ritual did you think about it regularly
was it one time you thought about it or
was it something you have an obsession
towards I had an obsession towards it I
mean I used to go I weren't used to work
in a video store which is the last job I
ever had in my life thank God and I used
to go to work almost every day and I
used to bring two magazines with me to
read on my breaks entrepreneur magazine
just to read about business and
everything else to read about what other
people are doing look for role models
and I used to carry an auto trader with
me and I used to look at Porsches that
were for sale yeah and people always
used to ask me what are you doing with
that auto trader magazine I'm like well
I'm just picking out the Porsche that
I'm gonna buy right when I'm which
probably got you a lot of crap I did
people made fun of it you actually had a
boss at that job tell me you know you
really shouldn't do that to yourself
John because it's it's very very likely
that that is never going to happen that
it's very likely that you you're never
going to have that car yeah that's
that's the kind of belief he was trying
to put in my head and I was like no you
don't realize that it's it's inevitable
that I will drive here it's sometime in
the near future with that car when I'm
not working for you and drop movies off
for you to put back on the show you can
buy a product but you also with that
product have got to condition yourself
you got to make it a must
you got to get a ritual that you do it
whatever you used to dream about you
thought was so huge you'll just live it
you'll live it like you live this
yesterday like we're all living the life
that we envision because we had to and
because we played this game with our
head we got the belief to be real by
seeing it enough time
enough times to our brain believed it
and then it made it happen which raised
the potential which made us take more
action which got us better results which
raised our beliefs again that's right
and then that's why that's why the rich
get richer and the poor get poorer so
instead of bitching about it change it
this process is the Holy Grail it's for
the whole game changes and anybody can
do it and they can do it in a few
minutes and if they do it a few minutes
each day then they get a different life
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed I made this video because
one life asked me to so there's a topic
that you want me to cover in the next
edition a belief life leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of the
points mentioned the video meant the
most to you is going to have an impact
on your life
leave it in the comments and I'll join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon